ça fait mal au poignet des prouesses que
éviter la tête à quatre pattes
en fait ce n'est pas parce que vous
aimez élise lucet ou pas elle a été
vraiment une jalousie derniers sondages
et animatrice préférée des français donc
ici vous l'aimez vous trouvez pas que
c'est une tête à claques et si vous
pensez que c'est une tête à claques
géraldine pourquoi cinq minutes de débat
c'est parti à lorsqu'elle fait quand il
utile et salutaire c'est une sorte de
erin brockovich des médias en revanche
je déteste sa méthode un peu procureur
un peu juge de paix en fait elle n'est
pas du tout dans un truc de journaliste
elle a son idée et elle va bille en tête
elle n'est pas là dans la thèse est dans
la synthèse elle est où dans l'antithèse
dans l'antithèse vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec moi un en fait elle
n'écoute pas les réponses elles sont
complètement des réponses c'est
insupportable et je m'en veux beaucoup
par rapport à les voter rocks rien des
derniers cash investigations où elle a
complètement trahi les victimes de du
médicament alors ça donc là pour
s'avouer que c'est une tête à claques
s'il vous plaît il ya quelqu'un qui fait
bouger son micro je crois que c'est vous
dire merci de quoi ça va me piron nous
prouve que cette attaque l'actos alors
moi oui oui oui parfois j'ai un peu
honte de faire le même métier qu'elle
parce que vous êtes dur je la trouve
d'une agressivité incroyable j'ai déjà
eu l'occasion de le dire ici
son clash avec stylisation sur le foot
est lamentable la manière qu'elle a eue
d'invectivés le pape
j'ai trouvé ça très choquant le pipeau
c'est minable
mais voilà il fallait quelqu'un pour
détourner les us et moi non non non
caroline alors moi je moi je me fiche
complètement de la tête qu'est là je la
trouve courageuse on la trouve qu'elles
font prend plein la tronche
alors qu'elle essaye juste de faire du
bien et de prouver des choses alors oui
effectivement on chante on effective
était la préférée des français avec wang
ou la compagnie tout est là et je serai
là je trouvais elle met les gens en face
à leurs contradictions donc oui
forcément c'est gênant ferme à l'aide
mais il faut bien quelqu'un qui fasse le
sale boulot à ben ahmed alouane lourds
du coach je suis désolé mais là on
verrait lémanique et on est bien ça ok
c'est vrai que c'est toujours du point
du côté du pouvoir et la bat maxime
mathieu de l'homme non ce que je voulais
dire voilà les filles seront honnêtes
qui pendant vingt ans est passée
totalement inodore et donc aujourd'hui
c'est vrai qu'au début de la guerre
là où tu as tort car ce meeting à sion
voilà les missions qui n'a jamais été
remise en question justement pour son
investigation et pour les enfants 15 ans
nés de sa retraite la bonne ici mais
c'est de partir les gens qui aujourd'hui
a un vrai style tapas lors de son
émission la notion à 50 % d'audience
soit moi est la vrai style vous enlevez
les juges et 50% de nos sombres
l'avis de le boire s'il vous plaît je
suis partagé la maintenant non mais moi
j'aime bien les gens qui me dérange
c'est une très belle manière après à
certaines de ses méthodes avec
lesquelles je ne suis pas d'accord et je
rejoins là dessus mais mais mais je
pense que j'aime les gens lisses à la
télé c'est fatigant j'en sais quelque
chose est très facile de faire des
choses elle fait son trou et là sont si
beaux si c'est ce que voilà pas bien non
elle est courageuse elle va au front est
elle a une ligne directrice à la suit
est lâche rien c'est vrai il ya
tellement de gens lâches faut qu
aujourd'hui que l c'est l'exemple
inverse chasse et là comme moi j'aime
bien les gens qui ont du style à la télé
c'est pour ça que mines dans un chat
croche à élise lucet de rien après peut
faire l aile et roule ou des fois mais
il n'est pas un peu relou voilà oui sauf
que les vrais journalistes sont tous
énervés par ce genre de méthode oui
pourquoi donc isabelle ça m'étonne de
toi fonsala pourquoi pas ce qui est en
soit une chose expliquait ce genre de c
l'info qui doit être la star est pas le
journaliste qui pose des questions alors
que l toute artificielle elle se met en
scène pour dire genre à vous avez dur
c'est dû rouvrir les portes sous entendu
habitat je suis très fort j'arrive à
faire un documentaire lors que tout le
monde ne ferme la porte
c'est artificiel complètement est-ce que
vous avez déjà vu dans le monde où je
suis garou qui sort quand même des très
grandes enquêtes du canard enchaîné les
journalistes qui se met en en valeur
comme ça en disant j'ai essayé d'avoir
monsieur untel m'a pas répondu je les
regrette non c'est la faulx qui est
prioritaire c'est pas la personne c'est
arrivé
isabelle oui elle se met mabiala pas
invective et le pape est une catho qu'il
parle elle l'a interpellé mais comme
j'étais content mais il faut qu'elle
fasse attention à nesle la croisée des
chemins effectivement faut se garder de
devenir un procureur officiel notre côté
a revanche certaines enquêtes comme par
exemple celle qui va sentir sur le coton
c'est ce qui s'appelle isabelle et
qu'ils appellent soyez on parle d' élise
us en général on va pas parler de l'
enquête sur le coton est ce que
certaines sont bien contents de 300m
thourjan hausse a compensé de style
éliminé c'est parce que justement est-ce
que vous l'aimez ou parle moi j'aime moi
messieurs si vous voulez jouer ou pas
est une que vous pourrez danger avec la
dette à la croisée des chemins il faut
pas qu alors officialise le côté
répondez pas à la question isabelle est
ce que vous l'aimez ou pas en tant que
journaliste elle est excellente donc
vous aimez le style et les us et oui
mais rim
c'est une tête à claques mais c'est sa
force elle est quasiment considéré comme
une super héroïne du fait des affaires
dans cash investigations et tête à
claques pourquoi parce qu'à plusieurs
reprises elle a refusé le paiement
allez son rôle c'est d'essayer brouillé
détester je crois qu'elle a
magnifiquement grand prix son rôle de
rabatteurs et je trouve qu'elle
distribue en fait à un énorme courage
parce qu'elle a quand même derrière elle
le patron de la bce qui quand même pour
l attaque et ses acquis et l'ancien de
goldman sachs
je rappelle juste que goldman sachs se
prétend être le banquier qui fait le
travail de dieu et elle a quand même ce
mec là on y est numéro 2 elle a quand
même ce mec là en ennemi numéro un et
elle va continuer par un amour glavany
continue à sortir quand même des
investigations et des informations qui
sont très importants et qui pourrait
même donner des bases de travail pour
l'état de gouverner avec ses parents
souvent les enquêtes se boucle des mois
à l'enfant des portes ouvertes et ça me
dérange bien voilà temps de sortir tous
les artifices à faire à côté dans la
grotte sur élise lucet pas pourquoi je
n'aime bien mine de rien ça d'idées avec
non gt gt sur france télévisions à
l'époque et on avait on avait couvert
tous les deux à des moments différents
la mort de michael jackson et si si
c'est vrai parce que vous avez fait des
journées spéciales oui sur france 2 sur
france 4 sur france 3 et élise lucet en
fait elle avait fait la tranche juste
avant moi et moi bien sûr je suis arrivé
les mains dans les poches non ah bon et
élise lucet pendant le le générique de
mon émission qui arrive juste après elle
voit que je n'ai rien elle voit qui
arrivent et donc elle me prend les
fiches coma et me donne ses fiches
housein pas hélas commence à regarder
on dit bien mais là je sors des trucs
pendant l'émission
michael jackson michael jackson michael
jackson en 2002 1 au massachusetts
akamai donné ces fiches et j'avais
trouvé ça très sain mais elle m'avait
bien dit elle était partie après m'avait
juste donné les doses comme ça elle sait
niveau lui l'arrière préparer sa
grandeur tu lui donnes et les autres
comme s'ils étaient déjà en 2009 en vrai
vous avez jamais bossé de votre vie en
fait ni pendant les études ni à la télé
ni rien on peut arriver les mains dans
les poches et nos missions vous parle il
peut arriver les mains dans les poches
mais je ne cautionne pas alors voilà
j'ai facilité garde la tête à claque du
paf
oui à 48% non à 53 ans un peu comme ici
vous êtes un peu partagé comme nous chez
bouheben merci d'avoir réagi à sa merci
au revoir merci à eux
[Applaudissements]